[Musique]
alors partout pour vous trouver au peu
importe où vous vous trouvez dans le
monde
c'est adam canada en direct de montréal
11h15 preures de montréal une heure
beaucoup plus avancé si vous trouvez en
europe cinq heures au moins d' avance
sur nous et puis ailleurs bien ça
déboule 12h en asie dans certains pays
bienvenue donc à montréal et autour de
la table nous avons ismaël cette semaine
est allé se chantal bonjour à vous deux
bonjour c'est fait alors mes collègues
de radio canada international sont un
des avantages aujourd'hui un handicap
passe comme s'il jouait un petit peu
enfin certains sports c'est pas qu'il le
manque de taille ou de nom c'est qu'elle
manque de connaissance ils ne savent pas
c'est quoi le sujet des missions mais
c'est normal c'est la tradition vous le
savez est pour vous aider vous aussi à
la maison à découvrir le sujet de la
semaine en vous faisant de cette vidéo 5
images donc cinq chances pour vous
d'attraper la balle au vol alors
premières images le service technique
use aussi et me dit les prêts dans 5 4 3
2 voici les premières images qui s'en
vient mais faudra être précis dans la
réponse je serre liées au monde de
l'enfance ont su congés parentaux la
natalité c'est épuisant vous est
épuisant c'est ben oui vous l'avez ces
quelques jours il a suffi d'une image
mais on le sait ismaël c'est notre
meilleur en fait voici sur ce thème des
congés parentaux voici la question que
l'on pose cette semaine c'est la
question qu'on amène au devin de
l'émission le reste du canada peut-il
copier le modèle québécois de congé
parental congés parentaux congé parental
les deux sont possibles il ya aussi
congé de maternité c'est pas la même
chose qu'un congé par an voilà ya
beaucoup de choses à découvrir
par rapport à ça je vous montrons pas
tout de suite la question numéro 1
on va avoir une petite conversation
ensemble est-ce que le d'entre vous ont
déjà bénéficié je peux d'ailleurs vous
avez pas encore parfois non non pas
encore j'en ai fait des gens qui s'y
disent oui j'en ai bénéficié au départ
enfin j'ai eu quelques soucis de santé
et puis j'ai eu plus de temps que les
autres mamans normalement mais c'est des
moments très très agréable et puis très
important c'est vraiment un pivot il ya
aussi des questions financières qui sont
reliés à ça si vous devez revenir au
travail rapidement
vous avez non seulement pas le temps de
souffler physiquement mentalement
psychologiquement tout cela c'est que il
ya vous avez des soucis des soucis
d'argent et il ya le conseil je pense
mondiale du travail non un peu plus
formelle pour ça c'est le côté où
jusqu'à l'organisation internationale du
travail yoichi vous nos élites et la
nationale 3 on a toujours la réponse
on recommande un minimum de deux
semaines
que pas tous les pays sont d'accord avec
çà parce que le régime de congé parental
congé de maternité ça n'existe pas dans
tous les pays non non non tu d'accord il
ya même à la aux états unis il ya des
gros chose qui nous inquiète qui sont
absentes
un rapport à ça on aura peut-être
l'occasion aujourd'hui d'en parler on va
surtout parler du régime québécois
régime général et puis même on en dit
beaucoup de bien internationalement on
le compare aux meilleurs mais on se
demandait ce qu'on devrait appliquer ce
monde-là au reste du pays
le premier du canada en a souvent parlé
depuis cinq ans depuis qu'il est au
pouvoir mais on attend encore un geste
on va analyser sans simple on regarde la
première question aujourd'hui donc trois
jeux à l'émission sans bulls à la perte
pour le premier jeu seulement 20 boules
et c'est facile aujourd'hui la première
question
on va l'affiché pour le plaisir de tous
et chacun vous voyez un petit compteur
là en bas vous avez récemment 60
secondes 60 secondes 100 secondes pour
répondre
voici la question les maires de 25 à 29
ans perdre quel pourcentage le revenu au
canada durant les cinq années suivant la
naissance d'un enfant
malgré toutes les protections qu'on leur
accorde est ce que ces 4 % de leurs
revenus qui y passe b 14 % c'est 24%
ouest et 34% top chrono
voilà c'est pas pour ça c'est énorme
24% des continents 14% 14% à côté d'eux
si modeste j'espère qu'elle paraît plus
que ça or ces gens là c'est fin c'est
fait
au moins un d'entre vous donc 50%
d'entre vous avez la bonne réponse alors
qu' à la bonne réponse d'après vous
[Applaudissements]
24% je me serais dit quand même c'est un
gros trou dans les finances
tout est possible soit dit en passant
j'aurai comme dit tout à l'heure espérer
que vous faites pas la regarde pas ce
qu'ils faisaient même pas eu besoin des
100 secondes et dans les 60 secondes
seulement 30 secondes
la bonne réponse sur la fiche on est
capable maintenant techniquement
l'affiché d'abord drainage aux cinq
étoiles
voilà tout simplement 14 pour ça ça
c'est pour les femmes de 25 à 29 ans ok
mais c'est rodez l'a 25 à 39 ans ok si
on mélange que jadis tant annoncée
seulement 4 pour cent pour cent au
canada ce que je vais vraiment pas cette
différence
je sais pas c'est une bonne très très
bonne question
charles selon un spécialiste qui est
avec nous ok qui s'appelle le madame
harvey valérie harvey qui est connue si
vous faites un peu de lecture c'est une
écrivaine qui est également sur yonne
sociologue malin et voilà et puis elle
est chroniqueuse à l'occasion à radio
canada on va aller la voir sur skype
elle nous attend j'allais poser une
excellente question
bah oui justement pourquoi ces
disparités oui pour les femmes de 25 à
29 ans se croisent 7 à 9 cents de pertes
et au delà de 29 ans et 4 % pourquoi
cette différence en probablement parce
qu'on s'organise davantage on n'est plus
installé dans la carrière c'est juste
une hypothèse mais on constate sans
peut-être moins longtemps les femmes qui
ont les enfants plusieurs offres en
quarts et surtout au canada le québec
est une exception étaient les bons alors
parce qu'on parle du québec
vous savez on est une station
internationale donc on ne peut pas que
faire du nom brille à l'émission il va
falloir élargir à toute la bedaine comme
disent les québécois donc à les inclure
le canada et peut-être même tout le
corps s'il le fallait
le reste de la planète situé le régime
québécois par rapport au reste du monde
parce qu'on en dit beaucoup de bien mais
c'est pas nécessairement le premier camp
vient en tête lorsqu'on a à offrir de
meilleurs
aux femmes c'est vrai les pays nordiques
ont été les précurseurs dans les congés
parentaux
donc il ya eu la suède qui ont mis un
très long congé en la norvège aussi la
finlande l'islande même tout le plus
tardivement est allé au tour de l'église
années 2000 commencé à investir là-bas
mais le québec
étonnamment même si on n'est pas un pays
nordique qu'on n'a pas aux terres de
taux d'imposition que dans le reste des
nordiques
on a des politiques familiales qui se
rapproche de ses politiques familiales
nordique là c'est à dire ça prend deux
choses pour que ça fonctionne bien pour
seulement un congé parental efficace
après un réseau de garderies et
sécuritaire à l'est qu'elle aura avoir
confiance d'envoyer nos petits parce que
c'est très très important et aussi qui
est vraiment abordable qui va être pas
cher parce que sinon on vaut préférer
rester à la maison sans occuper la mare
v j'ai essayé moi hier et avant-hier
même ce matin j'ai encore essayé de
comparer les différents programmes
internationale à ce qui existe ici il ya
deux choses que j'ai compris à part ça
j'ai rien compris mais je sais que la
durée c'est important la durée d'un
programme est aussi la rémunération le
pourcentage par rapport aux salaires
qu'on va vous qu'on va accepter de de
poursuivre votre rémunération dans
certains pays c'est 100 % au québec je
ne sais pas quel est le pourcentage mais
ça aussi c'est un facteur important la
rémunération dans l'appréciation d'un
programme comme que massa se passe
présentement pour nous au québec on a
quand même un bon remplacement de revenu
le congé de paternité et de cinq
semaines dans le régime de base là le
plus utilisé par le para pour remplacer
75 pour ce samedi pour star du salaire
de base aux papas dont par exemple il ya
un maximum évidemment ce gang est
davantage que le maximum ça va être
moins que ça mais c'est un bon
remplacement par ce qu on dit par
exemple pour les pères qui les utilise
le corps gît faut que ça remplace au
moins 50% de leur salaire pour les
mamans la même chose le 18
même qu'on donne à la mer va lui aussi
être remplacé à 60% par lasser 18
semaines là et ensuite on a ce qu'on
appelle ici même pas rentable qui sont
trente deux semaines et là aussi on un
très bon remplacement pour les saints et
cette première semaine on va remplacer
60 est petit ça demain tu semaine on va
avoir un emplacement de 55 pour ça donc
quand même un appauvrissement là il faut
prévoir un petit peu de l'économie qui
reste la plupart des couples que j'ai
rencontré c'est ce qui se passe devant
on va faire des économies non membres
présents présentement les images d'une
vidéo préparée par un lieu bureau
d'avocats au québec qui qui essaie
d'expliquer aux gens à combien vous
pouvez recevoir en compensation endurer
ça dépend si c'est votre premier enfant
deuxième enfant troisième enfant ça
devient très compliqué et en assure le
site du gouvernement
je me suis perdu je dois vous avouer si
j'avais à déterminer aujourd'hui à quoi
m'attendre parce que je j'attends un
enfant bientôt je serai inquiet de ne
pas trouver une réponse facilement est
ce que vous vous qui est une spécialiste
vous pouvez vous y retrouver où vous
avez noté le même souci même problème on
est beaucoup j'ai été marrant aussi a
donc moi aussi je vais consulter les
sites gouvernementaux dont capable
chercheurs utilisent est heureusement le
régime québécois d'assurance parentale
et facilement on peut téléphoner
donc on peut poser des questions
précises si on trouve pas l'information
sur le site web si c'est un peu
mélangeant est aussi un tableau qui
résume assez bien ce qui peut compliquer
les choses c'est qu'on peut faire un
choix différent du régime de base donc
là on vient un petit peu complique les
choses
est ce que je regardais ici le bio pour
montrer l'on me donne encore plus de
détails si on est malade c'est des
choses comme ça c'est pas tout à fait la
réalité ici pour la plupart des paroles
on espère faut l'être donc ça c'est des
situations qui sont un petit peu à part
généralement sur le site gouvernemental
on peut les mettre de côté
dans le cas des licences multiples pour
l'effort québec ait rien qui se passe du
tout a donc vous avez le même congé
parental que vous ayez eu deux ou trois
offres et serait un problème de réalité
parce que je pense que le travail est un
peu différent surtout c'est arrivé chez
des amis ceux vance avait des enfants
qui m'appelait mature et donc ils vont
être à l'hôpital
j ai longtemps avant l'arrivée à la
maison vous de votre congé parental est
presque épuisé donc ça c'est un problème
que le gouvernement est au courant donc
on va s'y avère assez bientôt j'espère
que ça va fonctionner mais ça reste qu'
il reste quelques petites choses à
régler
et quand on a des questions n'hésitez
pas à téléphoner vont vraiment répond
aux questions précises qu'on peut avoir
heureusement on n'a pas besoin
téléphoner vous êtes là à l'issue d'une
question oui donné que le modèle
québécois est très très apprécié et très
généreux est-ce qu on devrait s'attendre
à ce que ce modèle là soient facilement
calquer ailleurs si oui quels sont les
ingrédients qui devraient être réunies
dans les autres provinces les conditions
qui devraient être réunies pour que ce
modèle soit facilement exportable mais
moi je pense que ce serait effectivement
une bonne idée de l'exporter et en tant
que sociologue
j'ai regardé d'autres pays où il y avait
des modèles très généreux comme au japon
optez et dans les plus généraux mangou
est pratiquement pas utilisé par le papa
ibrahima est toujours utilisé mais avec
toujours une station aussi parce qu'on
risque de faire ton enfant donc avant
que l'on mette des belles conditions
bien au programme gouvernemental
il faut souvent quelque chose de prêt
dans la société en général c'est à dire
faut qu'ils le désirent
pour les parents la mère souvent déjà
présents ce désir là souvent abordé les
congés maternité qui sont déjà là aussi
les phoques et un désir des deux parents
d'en faire plus de renoncer à une partie
de son salaire souvent c'est le corps
d'avoir d'avoir du temps la maison de
savoir que ça va pas nous nuire
quand on va revenir sur le marché du
travail parce que ça c'est un autre
enjeu par exemple vous avez parlé des
états unis dans votre introduction aux
états unis revient rapidement au travail
parce que sinon ça va être et discuter
comme une personne qui trahit
l'entreprise qui sacrifie d'entreprise
pour amélie
donc après sur façon dont on va faire
travailler son entreprise il y aurait
aucune protection
par la suite un congé de maternité aux
états unis sa cause des problèmes donc
on peut planter un congé sans penser à
ça sans penser aux fêtes du ressenti des
uns commence est vu par exemple congé de
paternité
dans tous les cas pas pour tout à fait
j'allais rebondir par rapport au congé
de paternité
parce que c'est quelque chose qui est
relativement nouveau dans certaines
sociétés
pourquoi est il si important pour les
pères de bénéficier de ses congés en
tant que sociologue
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus donc ça c'est mon sujet préféré
il en a parlé lors da pour les papas
c'est important parce qu'ils vont
acquérir une confiance
donc premièrement ils vont découvrir que
eux aussi sont capables en france mais
qui sont compétents
donc il rien mieux que l'expérimentation
pour s'en rendre compte
on sait quand aussi encore des droits
pas que non seulement ils vont sentir
plus compétents à cause qui ont
expérimenté la vie quotidienne avec bébé
et sur un truc cinq semaines au québec
ce qui est relativement court mais qui
est immense si on regarde son compère
trésorerie du monde c'est assez rare
d'avoir un aussi long congé à la
naissance de l'enfant excepté dans les
pays nordiques qui agit pas vu d'autres
exemples on s'est rendu compte que dans
mon étude que j'ai fait les papas ça va
changer complètement leur vision de ce
que c'est prendre soin de vous j'en ai
au départ qui vont illustrer cela de la
façon la plus extraordinaire
ils m'ont dit quand tu rentres à la
maison soir là parce que lui de retour
nous travaille bien sûr rendre la maison
qui est ta conjointe et sur le divan en
pyjama qui à la fin de journée qui dit
ouah je pense qu'avant je me serais dit
à la presse au moulleau aujourd'hui
assez relax journée en famille alors que
quatre expérimenté lavier qu'un baby tu
dis donc pour lui c'est fou en fait
c'est un renversement de la situation en
sont en partie complètement changé parce
qu'il expérimentait
m donc ça c'est bon pour le pape a aussi
aussi que dans le cerveau du père on
commence à faire des études
neurobiologiques lorsqu'albert c'est
tout petit nouveau en fait c'est charles
a donc on commence à se faire donc à
l'usr les papas avons développé des
liens dans les cerveaux pour reconnaître
le son de leur bébé banques sont aussi
équipés pour le frère et le tordu par
biologiquement parlant et pu faire
s'occuper de l'enfant et ce sont des
choses qui ont besoin de l'usr dont ils
ont besoin d'apparaître dont en prenant
soin de paix et non seulement les choses
sont bonnes pour le papa mais ils sont
bonnes pour les enfants pour les enfants
c'est ce que j'allais devenir
et oui c'est important qu'on peut
négliger sa attendre on sait que les
bébés qui ont vu un papa impliqué quand
on était jeunes on va avoir tendance à
réussir mieux à l'école avoir moins de
problèmes de comportement et pour les
filles avant un meilleur reste
évidemment donc c'est important aussi et
bien moi je parlerais de leurs membres
donc oui paris - tant que maman je
l'expérimenté le d'avoir un papa très
présent les enfants ils cep de soulages
la pression la charge mentale qu'on
appelle en sociologie pas dire de
confiance quand tu pars que l'enfant est
avec la même personne
un toit ou le pas par sa part donc j'ai
développé une conscience envers mon
conjoint qui me sert quand je pars faire
conférence de quelques parents les
enfants et pour moi qui le soir ce qui
arrive aussi donc ça c'est très bien ici
pour la pression pour moi sur les
épaules entamant en charge mentale et
même la charge de travail le travail
qu'on a à faire mais au québec une d'un
tunnel sur ce sujet là et se démarque
savoir si le congé avait changé la façon
dont on se sépare les tâches
on a remarqué une chose d'important
après l'implantation du mqrp le congé
qui dureront nantes où l'eau qui peut
être acquis par énumère la charge que
les pères forme dans les tâches
domestiques ne savent pas vraiment
changé donc ils s'impliquent pas
davantage qu'avant
pour cela je vous la vaisselle sauf que
le soin aux enfants est pratiquement
visé également au québec seulement
depuis ce temps là il ya eu une montée
et puis le le congé parental prolongé
que permis que les barèmes caisse co
auteure de tu as à prendre soin de leurs
enfants que les maires et moi en tant
que cela je dirais pour avoir un
portrait plusieurs heures aux visiteurs
que ça aussi rapport aux liens qui
développe avec leur bébé pendant ce
congé la queue aux liens qui veulent
garder par là sous de bon ok c'est quoi
un bébé ça la charge que ça représente
un enfant
ils veulent continuer à avoir un lien
avec la fédé mais après avoir tourné
donc c'est une très bonne nouvelle
il faudrait maintenant faire un petit
peu plus pour les tâches domestiques
mais on a relevé des futures je voulais
savoir ce que est ce que les congés
maternité et paternité
ça coûte cher pour la société parce que
vous disiez tantôt que bon il ya des
pays nordiques qui ont mis ça en place
très tôt avec des taux d'imposition plus
important qu'au québec mais au québec on
en a installé avec des impositions des
taux d'imposition moins important que ce
que dans les pays nordiques est ce que
c'est ça coûte cher ou c'est finalement
un choix politique plus qu'un choix
économiques
mais évidemment c'est plus cher que si
on fait rien mais il faut pour mettre
dans la balance les conséquences de rien
faire pas dire aux appelant à ce que les
gouvernements parlent de faire en
mettant en congé
un label politique familiale lorsque
nécessairement faire plaisir aux
citoyens ou soulager leur charge mentale
contribuer à l'égalité ça c'est des
beaux discours et souvent ce qui veut le
faire en remettant sont en place c'est
un peu boosté la natalité
parce qu'on se rend compte que la
natalité dans les pays occidentaux et
diminuer devenu en fait partout dans le
monde est devenu mais dans les pays
occidentaux elle est passée sous la
barre du taux de remplacement de la
population depuis des décennies donc
c'est à dire on peut pas
tout semblait par l'immigration on ans
après l'arrêt vraiment vraiment beaucoup
de monde donc les gouvernements on se
dire ok donc ça prend plus d'enfants pas
dans la population qu'on a chez nous
comment on va faire ça paie les parents
disent qu'ils sont surchargés et 10 qui
arrivent par kilo belle ceux qui en on
peut se dire j'y arriverai jamais donc
j'en aurai pas on observe ce phénomène
s'appelle une société de célibataire il
trop mobile dans les pays asiatiques
comme la corée du sud taïwan ou encore
le japon où là on va avoir des gens qui
vont faire soit le choix de travailler
et ne pas avoir d'enfant parce que c'est
trop compliqué soit qu'ils vont décider
d'en avoir parce qu'elle nous trouve un
conjoint ils veulent avoir des enfants
et là il en avoir deux ou trois donc
leur taux de natalité il est vraiment
génial il ya tellement pas mort il faut
ce choix alors que on sera mort
finalement quand on fait la moyenne du
taux natalité avec une société quinson
d'attenté continuent de descendre dès
qu'ils arrivent puisse remplacer
et là le problème d'une natalité qui est
très basse à long terme c'est vraiment
compliqué pour la meilleure main
d'oeuvre - ma mais oui parce qu'on a
personne qui travaille au japon là c'est
le gros enjeu lancement bakchich et on a
beaucoup de problèmes avec les gens qui
perdent leur retraite mais où il y aura
assez de gens pour payer sur cette place
n'est pas le problème en une natalité
est important partout ici même en syrie
où il a pris une quatrième personne qui
manque le feu au canada aussi là le
québec
il est là il donne l'exemple il donne
l'exemple et un exemple extraordinaire à
partager ici le gouvernement c'est à
dire le premier ministre justin trudeau
avant qu'ils soient élus a parlé d'un
programme national canadien oui madame
mais on attend on sait pas ce qui se
passe qu'est ce qui se passe à ce que
vous avez des échos vous moi je suis le
direct probablement pour la minus revoir
le premier ministre c'est peut être une
priorité et qui passait sous le tapis
j'ai l'impression aussi quelqu'un on
vient parler du des politiques
familiales
on a encore un peu de sensibilité qui
est relié
la définition des rôles dans la famille
surtout du côté des mamans on se dit
même si elle est bonne garderie même
s'ils sont sécuritaires même si elles
sont peu du fond dieu sait ce que je le
suis je l ai vécu on le vit tout je
pense oui mais c'est normal que j'avais
porté mon enfant à la garderie
donc quand un gouvernement dans un pays
qui te laisse supposer mains libres de
tes actions qu'on est on est quand même
dans un pays qui proche des états unis
le donc nos choix individuels sont prêts
à valoriser son trait reporter dibon
d'un choix politique familiale nous
devons pouvoir envoyer ton enfant à la
garderie et continue de travailler 20
dans certaines provinces à peu moins
passé j'ai surfé groupe de gens aussi
comme quelque chose ou on essaie
d'influencer un continue de travailler à
avoir une vie capitaliste être moins
familiale à avoir un désengagement de la
mer et c'est donc ça peut être plus
difficile peut-être pour certaines
communes movie chance mais moi mon avis
ça va commencer à changer parce que les
garderies sont très très très très cher
dans le reste du canada
on entend souvent des levées de la fin
août et autour de ça et je pense que
gilbert qui souhaite continuer à
travailler à cette fille abandonne parce
qu'ils n'ont pas le choix c'est pas
nécessairement un choix si ça vient
plomber ton budget de l'automne
d'envoyer ton marchand la garderie donc
je pense qu'on va y arriver
parce que c'est aussi un enjeu d'égalité
au bout du compte pour celles qui
voudraient consul est médecin et celles
qui voudraient continuer être professeur
de musique dont pourquoi l on a sacrifié
leur carrière le temps d'avoir des
enfants qui se rendent à l'école
donc ça devient un peu injuste donc de
toujours se poser des questions ok
est-ce que c'est toi ou mon voisin papa
ou pas moi qui va sacrer la carrière se
voit c'est la mer il va prendre ces
décisions là je me dis c'est re devenir
l'enjeu
peut-être les prochaines années
c'est sans renier totalement ma première
question justement si vous aviez des
recommandations à formuler pour la mise
en place d'un programme pancanadien sur
ce plan là que diriez-vous exemple
j'irai pour le côté par canadien se
trouve qu est ce qui serait très
important ce serait d'abord d'implanter
des garderies donc d'avoir vraiment déçu
devant sion un système de garderie qui
va permettre d'abord confiance autant de
confiance à l'école quand on a envoient
leurs enfants à l'école
théoriquement on se dit bon ben il est
pris est pris en charge efficacement sa
sécurité est assurée il ya en suisse les
étapes de développement et je peux dire
qu'il faut leur donner de l'éducation la
garderie nécessaire mal n'est ce que je
veux dire c'est que on suit les étapes
émotionnelle d'un enfant a maintenant
deux ans donc on connaît ces étapes là
maintenant et on les suivait on s'ajuste
donc un don d'un réseau comme ça ils
coûtent trop cher donc qu'ils vont être
financés aidé par le gouvernement appuyé
vraiment est encadrée par le
gouvernement aussi avec des inspections
l'eau qui est restée régulière ont suivi
je pense que nous pourrons commencer à
envoyer davantage d'enfants pour pouvoir
continuer à travailler et à ce moment là
comme on le fait au québec quand on
plante un régime beaucoup plus généreux
pas ça existe au canada le régime
d'assurance c'est sur l'assurance emploi
qu on appelle ça un mot de programme
mais c'est présent particulièrement pour
la mère donc je pense qu'à ce moment là
qui pourrait mettre des choix différents
peut-être au régime plus généreux qui
serait davantage utilisé par les parents
parce qu'il verrait l'utilité de
l'utiliser il aurait confiance aussi
qu'un autre alternative
donc il faut que les garderies soit
possible à temps partiel ou si c'est pas
tout le monde qui veut abandonner
kiki qui veut et le choix n'est pas
seulement doit d'abord donner ma
carrière ou complètement occupé les
enfants à la maison et il faut qu'ils
aient le temps partiel possible aussi
pour ceux qui ont et ont la possibilité
de faire un bon plat temps partiel a
fait d'avoir les enfants des jours à la
maison avec eux donc c'est que ce soit
va rien à ce sujet là je pense cet
enfant
j'ai lu ça il ya quelques jours ils en
ont de la loi oblige les employeurs à
réduire la journée de travail à césar
c'est une option qui est qui et à faire
trop mère césar seulement de travail je
sais qu'en france et travailler parce
que ben oui mais il faudrait pas le
genre et danse en soi un papa qui
travaille à l'extérieur pourrait
demander dès qu'on appelle des
aménagements de ton travail
moi j'ai interviewé beaucoup de papas
dans les jeux vidéo est bien les jeux
vidéo ont souvent accès à ce type de
journée flexible donc tu rentres tu es
leurs idées leurs et le résultat est là
ou pas beaucoup de parents m'en parler
comme quelque chose qui vient très
positivement parce que faisait le choix
d'un prix très très tôt aux bébés ont
reçu que souvent ça fait pas de grasse
matinée
non diedrick de rentrer très très tôt le
matin et ensuite ils partaient prêt tôt
pour aller chercher leurs enfants à la
garderie ballon et que la maman se
chargeait si on veut d'alain portes et
papa c'est comme ça c'est un aménagement
qui fonctionne très bien
donc il faut donner différents types
d'aménagements parce qu'on est
différents types de cours pour nos
différents types de d'aménagement donc
il faut que ce soit aussi pour les
parents de s'organiser en fonction de ce
qu'ils ont comme travail des x puisque
je trouve intéressant c'est que les
choses évoluent rapidement
si on suit les articles uniquement
publié par radio-canada ou radio rci là
depuis cinq ans on voit le programme
bonifié encore récemment je pense au
mois de janvier on a inclus une nouvelle
catégorie de parents pouvant bénéficier
des mêmes avantages que les parents
biologiques par exemple donc c'est pas
quelque chose qui est statique ça évolue
rapidement
il sent que les messages se rendent au
gouvernement ebay parce que c'est ça
fonctionne bien
c'était très drôle parlait mon études de
doctorat
j'ai interviewé des papas et des folies
gouvernement essaye d et lance des
petites rumeurs qui vont aussi au
programme
et j'étais en train de faire mais on est
sorti on allait couper le seul domaine
protégé des papas qui on allait
l'inclure dans les soins pas rentable de
toute façon ça changeait rien voilà les
papas que l'interview est pour
ça revenait sur le tapis mais qu'ils
n'avaient pas de questions à propos de
ça donc là on voyait qu'elle grandes
réactions dans la population à propos de
une possibilité de changement à au congé
de paternité et je le comprenais bien
parce que pendant les entrevues l'epa
ferait non miscibles de ne pas
sanctionner n'en sortira pas autorisé à
prendre cinq semaines c'est à dire que
la vision qu'on est encore traditionnel
c'est on voit que c'est la maman dans ce
qu'on appelle parental eu peur des gens
c'est le congé maternité qui s'éleva oui
voilà donc les père disait non si je
peux me marre des cinq semaines de ce
congé parental c'est son congé donc
illégitime aller chercher ce projet n'a
changé oui on y voit les exactement
alors ce qu'ils m'ont dit c'est moi car
j'ai cinq semaines marc wiltz et d'amour
au nom si je le prends pas c'est perdu
c'est à moi donc c'est mon congé donc je
vais vraiment l'utiliser donc c'est pour
ça que il faut faire attention donc le
gouvernement le port fait rien changé
parce que la réaction et evie lovelle
quoi et ils l'ont senti donc et je pense
qu'un aperçu à au congé au québec et
c'est pour ça qu'on le bénéfice pour soi
quand il l'a juste et ça a servi ou si
la natalité ça mais j'ai remonté la
natalité au québec
en tout cas moi j'ai bien compris une
chose madame hard et pour que ça
fonctionne ça prend un bon mari non ça
c'est vrai j'allais poser une dernière
question je sais pas pendant votre dr
est ce que vous êtes allé voir si les
pères utilisent réellement le temps qui
leur est accordée à s'occuper
véritablement de l'enfant ben ça c'est
une question hyper performantes et j'ai
eu deux petites de père pendant mon
congé
voilà les papas qui se sont appelés eux
mais c'est pas moi qui leur donne un air
ne l'est pas pas inutile en congé plus
tôt ptet les comics est donc c'est à
dire que ben il faisait à manger pour
les mamans il s'occupait du plus grand
si on avait un autre mais sinon il va
pas grand chose à faire parce que la
maman ce petit bébé il y avait à
l'allaitement et n'a rien à faire là
dessus a fait 70 avec le bébé dont tout
cas pas le moment
oui considéré qu'ils avaient été utiles
pour développer des liens avec la
enfants donc ça ça n'est pas beaucoup
la place que la vapeur sentais pas
légitime d'aller la chercher
parce que j'ai eu toute une autre série
de papa que j'appelais papa partenaires
ou l'allaitement c'est vrai problème au
contraire toulousain s'occupe elle
allait changer la couche pendant ce
temps là ils vivaient toutes les crèmes
par rapport à ben sur de petits
problèmes qui arrivent constamment
pendant le le développement de bébé
envisage donc c'est vraiment des parents
qui étaient partenaires dans leur
inquiétude partenaires dans leur joie
dans leur partage donc il est bien sûr
très très différemment qui sont est
infiniment utile qui trouvaient que cinq
semaines vraiment passé l'ont donc que
ce type de faire je pense que quelque
chose de voir comme je dirais avec la
maman il c'est normal parce que d'une
certaine manière nous en tant que maire
pour être une bataille vaut être capable
de tout faire pour avoir la réponse est
bien sûr le monde des super woman salut
souviens avoir donc je me dis moi dans
la mare je les u7 se clore ce désir là
d'avoir les réponses à toutes les
questions qui s'est pas facile à
décrocher c'est on sait en fait j'ai ma
professeure en islande qui me disait
toujours tu es qu'un une femme de la
génération se compare avec sa mère avec
sa grand mère on est toujours moins
bonnes qui on est toujours moins
impliqué cava d'espoir avec la fête
et quand on perd c'est pas avec ça c'est
normal
la perception et dire voilà madame
harvey ce fut un plaisir de vous avoir
avec nous via skype merci infiniment
d'avoir participé aujourd'hui
merci enfin et c'était donc l'écrivaine
et chercheuse sociologue valérie harvey
fantastique de l'événement on a vraiment
essayé de trouver les spécialistes
savent et répondent à toutes les
questions et c'est elle c'est rare on
verra on y va avec notre ce que je peux
jouer je dirais qu'avec la deuxième
question à l'émission henry qui a perdu
20 beau l'amour
là il ya trente bout la création
deuxième jeu à l'émission encore 60
secondes seulement pour répondre ou 100
secondes au choix l'affiché sans vous je
vous comprends pas alors on garde ça
ensemble la question tout le monde que
voilà lequel de ces pays possèdent selon
vous d'après vous
le congé de paternité le plus généreux
soit 2,60 à 480 jours
est ce la norvège à sb la suède s et la
finlande avec deux petits points ou sd
le danemark
quelle est la bonne réponse top chrono
moi c'est la finlande
pourquoi la finlande elle en a parlé
tous
oui mais elle fait partie d'abord des
pays d'origine dont on a mentionné mais
c'est aussi un pays qui je pense que
tout le gouvernement finlandais sont des
femmes en ce moment ok oui je sais qu'il
ya quelque chose à vous c'est votre
premier argument c'est un pays
landi nordiques que tu sais pas ce que
la par la cpi lassante nordiques c'est
la sortie nerfs mais généreux dans ces
pays là tout est agréable en norvège
alors finlande pour notre ami et c'est
pour ismaël ils voient ce passé 18
secondes
réponse bombay peut-être c'est aussi ma
j'irai avec un vous iriez de diviser
encore le vote alors je peux vous dire
que 100%
j'aimerais de mauvaises réponses c'est
la suède c'est la suède
mais ça c'est au niveau de la durée non
au niveau du remboursement des revenus
par rapport aux salaires
ouf vous faites c'est la norvège dont
combat on va dire on va dire en suède
oui oui grosse durée pour vous la
société mais peu d'argent 70% 91 en a
pas oui par la finlande c'est quelque
chose c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire non j'ai pas le chiffre
exact
j'oserais dire que c'est 100% mais je
devrai allait revérifier ouais ouais
c'est toujours deux critères au moins 1
et 2 puis c'est pas trois ou quatre ans
quand on évalue les pommes et les
oranges tous les deux son rang la
troisième question
ben on ne peu près de la troisième
question je vais vous montrer ça c'est
pour en savoir plus notre vidéo numéro
66 24 2000 et puis si on va sur le site
web de rci et ça sera affiché d'ici
quinze minutes
là c'est un privilège enfin bien que
vous mmes qui voyait sa les autres nous
c'est non nos articles sur la même
question depuis quelques années vous
allez pouvoir voir que ça évolue
rapidement
on a là seulement cinq ou six cette
semaine mais j'en avais beaucoup plus
que ça mais aujourd'hui on remonte la
nes m'en aller voir quand une maman un
enfant elle fait moins de revenus mais
regardez bien la manche est un père les
revenus du père vont augmenter la nôtre
imageur si elle viendra la mer voilà mes
romans théo père léthel mer var
augmenter ses revenus
ça donne voilà paraît que les employeurs
en plus de poche au pont du wouri
respect par rapport aux autres
travailleurs à l'homme qui est au
travail en plus de considération pour
les pour les promotions
il y en eu un appui sociétal ici est
d'aider niable en effet est rien pour le
jeune loup fou voilà donc il ya un
problème d'équité salariale vous faire
les hommes seul problème là où
évidemment le chalet un peu loin damas
damas vidéo j'ai capturé des de la
publicité je suis pas autorisé à faire
ça et j'espère que je vais vous montrer
que dans l'arctique alors d'où peut
aller d'un hyperlien à l'autre on
s'amuse
faire ça on a fini par aboutir à radio
canada comment fait mais on a fait le
grand écart
voilà vous vouliez la troisième question
vous avez 50 boules de perdues sur st
vous en avez seulement 32 personnes à
elle dont il avait gagné 20 vous n'aviez
pas perdu et il est rentré à 60 ans un
nombre de congés payés
c'est à peu près ça 70 % et 70 % êtes
pas enfin l'angle comme dans ce
troisième question
on joue tous ensemble encore une fois on
n'aura que 100 secondes ou 60 secondes
pour répondre en quelle année selon vous
le canada 1 faute à leurs frais at il
offert pour la première fois aux
nouvelles mères un congé de maternité
rémunéré en quelle année sa dette de
quels à nice et c'était le canada alan
québec qui a fait cette offre d'accord
tranquille c'était sur 161 par la 1951
notable au canada avant 1960 et 1961
1951 pour les annales d'armes
ça me semble très tarn 1951 pourquoi
1951 parce que c'était bien avant le
québec je sais que la révolution
tranquille a commencé ici dans les
années 60 et donc avec la révolution
tranquille il ya eu pas mal de
programmes chamboulement dans la société
y compris dans ses murs une explication
à je vous comprends entre le canada
était réveillée avant le québec tout ça
et si c'était le cas ça a dû se produire
avant la révolution à voir la révolution
tranquille de relégation j'aime beaucoup
ce sac où ça va tenir la route même
alors je 1950 à pour alice mais plus
pour vous reste qu'à tort selon des cinq
mais regarde de matha tardive
c'est terrible c'est désolant c'est
désormais garder cette date parce que
regarder la bonne réponse vous avez
conservé pour une g
je garde juste au lait et ils 71 c'est
le mouvement le québec c'est un jeu 110
vous avez perdu toutes vos bonnes je
suis triste mais c'est pas grave ça sera
du genre mais dans la vraie vie je gagne
oui c'est ça qui compte
ici c'était les jeux wii c'est virtuel
mais oui ça mais la réalité virtuelle
alternative
écoutez on est prêt pour la l'image de
la semaine
comment ça fonctionne l'image la semaine
du goût il ya rien à perdre des années
maintenant mais à deviner il faut juste
deviner quelque chose voilà je répond
par oui ou par non à vos questions tout
à fait très intelligente
ces escrocs on image de la semaine
quelle est l'image l'aspect 2010 n'ont
pas dadis oui dénonce pas les 10 et non
le coronavirus non non le déraillement
prenne sa robe
je suis resté une bonne réponse avec les
canadiens qui s'y trouvent sais ce que
c'est
les manifestations autochtones pourquoi
ce serait l'image la semaine sinon vous
passez ccc mal ce qui se passe en ce
moment vous vous êtes champions cette
semaine regardez c'est l'image de la
semaine effectivement et vous êtes
capable de nommer
les faits oui de livrer les faits on
vous écoute sur ces images
l'image la semaine que voici la
colombie-britannique communautés
autochtones de la colombie britannique
les les aînés où je pense que c'est lé
chef spirituel de la communauté
autochtone qui sont contre la
le traversée de la baie du pipeline à
travers leur territoire ancestral
car lewis testait les watts sous
huitaine voilà c'est ça voilà excusé il
feuillette la communauté et ils ont ils
ont reçu l'appui de beaucoup d'autres
que moi là donc il ya eu un arrangement
des autres communautés autochtones du
canada par solidarité bloque aussi les
voies ferroviaires du pays bloquant donc
le pas le trafic de passagers
voilà c'est fini c'est fermé tout à fait
rides et les marchandises s'est
interrompu en plusieurs endroits
notamment dans l'est tout à fait et
aussi vers les états unis on craint
maintenant qu'il n'ya pas possibilité
d'envoyer les produits du canada par
voie ferroviaire le principal au
transport des marchandises
ouais c'est un blocage économique à
l'échelle du pays alors c'est pure c'est
pire qu'une il ya aussi un problème par
rapport au chauffage
j'ai entendu dire ce match ce qui se
chauffe au propane nous sommes pas des
galeries total donc il ya un problème de
ravitaillement et puis voilà les
voyageurs aussi se trouve que nous et
sur le plancher voilà obligé de prendre
l'avion ou l'autobus loto du cheval a
alors tout le monde est affecté par sa
faim touche du doigt ceux de la scission
c'est ça alors c'est à piller écoutez il
ya plusieurs bandes amérindienne qui ont
dit oui au projet de gazoduc d'un an
mais ces bandes là ont d'abord signé il
ya des années des générations de cela la
loi des indiens le gouvernement blanc à
l'époque et les les chefs autochtones en
c'est strauss comme ça qu'on les appelle
eux disent nous on n'a jamais signé
cette loi là on reconnaît rien à ça on
les les autres ont pu signer mais nous
ça ne concerne pas et nous on a la
gestion de toute la responsable de tout
le territoire
peler les représentants des bancs dessus
simplement leur territoire qui peuvent
au trésor la réserve voilà examens
passés protéger quelque chose comme ça
oui gaz lingway c'est pas tellement
l'occasion
c'est la longueur de la conduite annick
fallait de l'argent et ce à travers ce
territoire ancestral c'est exact
et c'est pas le premier cas de soucis
qu'on avait avec les communautés
autochtones ou de traiter ancestraux qui
la reconnaissent certains droits
c'est une soirée suisse à seulement
reparler la semaine prochaine peut-être
même à cette émission faudra voir
notamment dans à quelqu'un en fonction
des développements qu'on aura on n'a pas
de ce matin j'entendais dire qu'il faut
s'en tenir au respect des lois quelque
chose qu'on soit quelques 10 du doigt
mais je sais pas trop je n'ai pas le
droit de manifester existe mais le droit
respecté aussi les règles il faut donc
c'est des injonctions tg lieu deux mois
la jonction qui sont en vigueur il a
fait ils sont pas encore respecté en
ontario a par am arrière ça ils ont
réglé le problème
les policiers sont intervenus dans tous
les cas quand on parle de droit c'est
toute sorte de droit partout parce que
c'est peu plus la russie en certains
droits sur leurs territoires et des
droits qui sont reconnus par les nations
unies en landes date tout à fait qu' il
faut tenir compte de tout ça tout à fait
donc à développer à ercis a su jeter
votre patron je voudrais développer
oui oui la suivre dans cette affaire
mais pour moi suivre c'est ça fait le
tour du monde cette nouvelle par le
corps à la virus évidemment qui poursuit
qui poursuit sa course cinq ans ouais
m'écouter merci beaucoup d'être mais
cela merci montagne de travail que vous
avez quand même monté vers la colline de
l'émission merci pour l'invitation à la
semaine prochain
[Musique]